we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman steady md lets you maintain
a meaningful long lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with any anytime over
phone or video chat you don't need
insurance it's only 99
a month with no other fees or co-pays
visit
steadymd.com pacman to get started
we actually have some good news to start
with today obviously this is a context
of lots of really bad news but it seems
as though dr anthony fauci's completely
outrageous in adversarial relationship
with the white house
is going to be repaired the day that
president-elect joe biden is sworn in
just six and a half weeks from now
because we've learned that joe biden
spoke to dr fauci
and has first and foremost confirmed
that dr fauci
um joe biden wants dr fauci to stay
in his role at the nih as the head
um essentially the the the head of
of fighting pandemics as the case
effectively is in the united states and
in addition to this
joe biden has offered dr anthony fauci
the role of chief
medical advisor to the white house and
dr fauci
says that he accepted this offer on the
spot here is video of anthony fauci
being interviewed on nbc by savannah
guthrie
they also spoke about a hundred day
masking campaign which
uh joe biden has already asked dr fauci
about
and i want to talk about that as well so
let's take a look at this clip
joe biden said in an interview yesterday
on his
inauguration he's going to ask americans
to wear a mask
for 100 days he said just 100 days not
forever
is that enough or do you feel like that
might put an artificial time limit
on how long people may need to be
wearing masks
no no i he didn't mean it that way i
spoke to him about that what he wants he
just wants to get and it's a good idea
uniform he's saying hey folks trust me
everybody for a hundred days now it
might be that
after that we still gonna need it but he
just wanted
everybody for a commitment for a hundred
days and i discussed that with him and i
told him i thought that was a good idea
he also said when he spoke to you he
asked you to continue in your role which
you've had under six presidents
but also to serve as his chief medical
advisor
will you do that did you say yes
oh absolutely i said yes right on the
spot yeah we have to hope
that the combination of the vaccine
starting to roll out although likely
a bit of a slower rollout than we would
like
combined with sanity entering the white
house combined with hopefully better
treatments becoming available
we are hoping that this will give us a
much better march than we are likely to
see in january and february
and then hopefully this will give us a
better second quarter of 2021 than we
are likely to see
in the first quarter of 2021 and then
hopefully we will have a better second
half of 2021
than what the first half will be um but
let's talk
briefly about this hundred day mask
thing
i talked about this yesterday during uh
during a live stream a little bit
this is already being framed as some
kind of wing
authoritarian nightmare police state
where joe biden is deploying
federal troops to force people to wear
masks now i want to remind you
the authoritarian nightmare is trump and
trump's leaving it was
trump who used the military for domestic
law enforcement
and sent the military into protests that
was authoritarian
it's trump who claims he won an election
that he lost
that's authoritarian it's trump who has
been attacking
a free press and attacking individual
journalists that's authoritarian and i
could go on
joe biden can't actually affect a mask
mandate
don't forget this when we hear about joe
biden will ask
all americans to wear a mask that's
literally what it will be
he will ask americans to wear a mask he
can also
and will ask governors to push mask
wearing
and put in place mask mandates at least
from the standpoint of
commerce and businesses joe biden cannot
legally put in place a mass mandate so
everybody's saying
the mass mandate he will put in is
authoritarian
he will not because he cannot put in
place a mask mandate now lots of people
will ignore it
hopefully many won't and we'll be able
to work together to reduce
the number of cases and the number of
deaths as we start to vaccinate people
hopefully as soon
as a week from today but the big story
is dr fauci
staying on and getting a bigger role
government living
in reality is going to come back we
really need that desperately we also
need to be revering the doctors that are
spending their careers
trying to keep people healthy under
trump dr fauci
started to need full-time armed security
for himself and for his family this is
not normal
that's insanity there are very sick
people in this country that made
armed security a necessity for dr fauci
we have to reverse that now now you
might be wondering
why would joe biden do this isn't joe
biden worried
and jealous that anthony fauci might end
up with a higher approval rating than
joe biden
and the answer is no we're not worried
about that joe biden is not going to
uh determine which doctors he hires
based on whether they have higher or
lower approvals
remember donald trump complaining at a
rally
and at press briefings that somehow
fauci has a higher approval rating than
trump
uh has we've had uh terrible luck really
uh it's really dr
fauci's bad luck when we needed him the
most and not that we didn't need him
during ebola
not that we didn't need fouchy during
hiv and sars we did
but when we needed fauci the most during
a global hundred year pandemic
we have a president who doesn't listen
to fauci
and actually attacks fauci to such a
degree that fauci needs armed security
it's truly insane
the good news is that at least this
aspect of the
insanity of this administration is going
to be reversed
it's important to keep an eye on the
things that administrations
do in the waning days of a presidency
barack obama did many things in the last
days of his presidency
george w bush also did and one of the
things
that the outgoing trump administration
did is on december 1st
they rolled out their new citizenship
test
for new prospective us citizens
why did we need a new test well we
didn't but the trump administration
put one in place and not only is it
filled with right-wing bias
it's also riddled with hilarious factual
errors legal errors historical errors
they can't do
anything right in spirit nor by the
letter so for those who aren't familiar
with this test
anyone not born a citizen needs to pass
an
oral test to become a citizen to become
naturalized
20 questions you have to pass 12 and
that's a 60 correct answer rate the new
test is filled with questions about most
things
about things that most people born in
the us as citizens don't even know
specific questions about
alexander hamilton the trump
administration has put in
questions about the 10th amendment which
most people know nothing about and it's
clear that the idea is to just make it
more difficult to become a naturalized
citizen and in order to do so
you have to sort of buy into a bunch of
right wing trumpian propaganda
some of them actually say these new
questions
that the correct answer is something
that is just factually wrong here's an
example
question who does a u.s senator
represent the study guide says the study
guide
says the correct answer is citizens of
the state
now this might seem obvious but senators
represent all people
in a state it includes permanent
residents as an example
now this is clearly an anti-immigration
type of
answer senators don't represent illegals
now
in some ways senators do represent
undocumented immigrants but even without
arguing that
the correct answer can't be all citizens
because permanent residents
here legally with green cards have
representation from senators so it's
it's factually wrong here's another
wacky question from trump's new
citizenship test
what are three rights of everyone living
in the united states
and you can choose from freedom of
expression freedom of speech freedom of
assembly
freedom to petition the government
freedom of religion the right to bear
arms those would all be acceptable
missing is the right to a lawyer the
right to due process the right to equal
protection
the right to freedom from unreasonable
search and seizure it just those
are not listed as acceptable answers the
right to bear arms which
is listed is not absolute felons as an
example
are limited in their right to bear arms
but the right to due
process is completely missing it's a
factual joke
and then one more for you what is the
supreme law of the land
the study guide says the answer is the
u.s
constitution this is utterly insane the
law of the land
includes the constitution all
laws statutes and treaties that we have
and that's even
in the constitution the constitution
says
that the full law includes
statues and law statutes not statues
statutes
laws and treaties trump couldn't even
pass this test
let me put it a different way even trump
couldn't pass the bogus test they've
created
even as they delineate the right answers
and trump also couldn't pass
the test that we had up until december
1st this is really horrible and it's
sort of a
uh it encapsulates so much of what is
wrong
about the perspective that is espoused
by this administration now
the good news is this is something that
joe biden should relatively quickly be
able to
fix once he takes office and i hope that
he will
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at deepakman and we'll be back right
after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important
core insights from each book so it's
perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show is
mostly funded by
individuals just like you they're
they're no different than you it's
people exactly like you who grab a
membership at joinpacman.com
you get the daily commercial free audio
and video streams of the show
as well as the daily bonus show the
members only newsletter and so many
other things
sign up at joinpackman.com big news
overnight donald trump's personal lawyer
76 year old rudy giuliani has tested
positive for coronavirus donald trump
confirming the diagnosis via twitter
yesterday saying
quote rudy giuliani by far the greatest
mayor in the history of new york city
and who has been working tirelessly
exposing the most corrupt election by
far
in the history of the united states has
tested positive for the china virus
back to calling it the china virus get
better soon rudy we will carry on
now of course there is nothing
surprising
about this rudy giuliani has been flying
daily all over the country for weeks
sitting in rooms with 100 or more
different people every day
many without masks all to promote bogus
voter fraud conspiracies
the only surprising thing about rudy and
coronavirus
is it took this long for rudy to test
positive so there's a few elements to
this story
first is the personal health element
rudy 76
at minimum he's overweight i don't know
if he would be considered obese
unsure about other comorbidities so
question one is
how serious of a case will rudy have and
as with everybody i hope
he gets uh to experience a full and
speedy recovery
many people do not um that's question
one
part two how many people did rudy
giuliani expose or give the virus to in
the days prior to the positive test
he was all over different hearings
without a mask around lawmakers from
different states
also not wearing masks next to another
trump attorney jenna ellis
also without a mask so he may be another
super spreader
arizona's legislature has shut down
because they were all exposed by rudy
giuliani just a few days ago that's part
number two
part number three how does this impact
trump's continued voter fraud campaign
will they
keep having hearings and filing bogus
legal complaints with other attorneys
working for them
will rudy work from home who knows rudy
as of as of last night uh had been
checked into a hospital for treatment
and then fourth and this is just amazing
the number of people convinced
that this is actually part of the
conspiracy is stunning
i jokingly tweeted yesterday and anyone
who knows me knows it's obvious satire i
posted to twitter
a fake conspiratorial post again
obviously joking i said quote doesn't
anybody find it a little suspicious
that just as rudy was traveling all over
the country ready to expose affidavits
that would overturn the election
he gets coveted and now has to stop
exposing the fraud
it's too convenient now that was a joke
and somehow this tweet got caught in
some kind of twitter trending topics
thing and people were agreeing with me
people responded
yeah it is a bit of a stretch a woman
named marlene responded yep
and i don't believe trump had it either
a woman named debbie
suggested rudy doesn't really have kovid
but that quote i wonder if trump
sidelined him
because of all the losing it got so
bad that i had to post a follow-up tweet
where i said holy you know what
i can't believe i have to add this
but my post is satire you lunatics
so that's very very bad and of course we
wish rudy the best and a full recovery
and at the same time we hope that he
will drop the bogus voter fraud nonsense
because it's been
so so corrosive to democracy
rudy giuliani positive for coronavirus
and
in the hospital and we now must
discuss um georgia
georgia which will determine who ends up
controlling the senate beyond january
20th let's go to that next
so this is super important for us to
understand and think about
we briefly spoke about it on a bonus
show
last week but now that we're closer to
these georgia senate runoff elections
let's dive in even further there is a
contingent of trumpists
in georgia who are thinking of
boycotting the special senate runoff
elections and staying home
why are they thinking of doing that
because they're mad that as they see it
as donald trump has been telling them
the georgia republican governor and
secretary
uh georgia secretary of state haven't
fought hard enough to give trump the
election even though joe biden won it
okay that's even though joe biden won
and trump lost there are republicans who
are thinking of boycotting the senate
runoffs
because they think brian kemp and the
secretary of state in georgia
brad raffensberger should have done more
to steal the election
for donald trump that's some trumpists
and they're saying
boycott the january 5th senate elections
because we want to punish georgia
republicans for doing that
other trumpist republicans are thinking
of boycotting the january 5
senate election because they believe
it's rigged
and just like it was rigged against
trump they believe that they voted for
trump in large numbers
but because of the rigging they lost
they likewise believe
if we vote on january 5 it also is
rigged so we're going to boycott in
protest there's two different sides
to this boycott now the republican party
realizes
that if they keep calling it rigged they
might inadvertently encourage people not
to vote which will make them lose both
of these senate elections which would be
great for us
but bad for them so it is rally on
saturday night in georgia
yes there are rallies and we will get to
clips later donald trump was at the
same time attacking the system in
georgia as rigged claiming he really won
georgia
attacking governor brian kemp attacking
the secretary of state
but also saying and by the way we really
have to vote in georgia
sort of an incoherent message if it's
all rigged and fake and stolen
why is it that people should vote isn't
it going to happen again now i've
received a ton of emails
from our viewers saying david you should
participate in this
encourage or start playing up that it
was
rigged to trick and encourage
republicans
into not voting it would be really great
because control of the senate is riding
on this
you should encourage republicans to
boycott get him to stay home
and then john ossoff and rafael warnock
will win here's my thought on this
for more than a decade on this program
i've been calling for
and advocating for and encouraging more
civic engagement which starts with
voting
everyone should vote has been my
perspective and my mantra for years
i believe in total the country is better
off with more people
having a stake feeling involved and and
by the way i think it's better for the
progressive movement to have higher
turnout republicans uh know
that they do better by suppressing the
vote they have a different view
i don't want that i want more voting and
i want more engagement so
it would be immoral for me to now
say republicans you should stay home
because it was rigged especially when it
wasn't
rigged other than their own voter
suppression which failed to actually
give them the win
so it would be morally wrong and
antithetical to my beliefs to start
encouraging
republican voters not to vote now that
being said
if republicans as a strategy want to
encourage
their own voters to boycott the election
i'm not going to get in the way
this is sort of like i would never wish
death on anyone
but i could at the same time recognize
that sometimes the world is better off
with certain people not around
um i would never hope that someone
becomes ill or dies
but i can still feel okay saying this
was a bad person that did bad things
were better with them not doing those
things anymore
similarly i believe in voting i believe
in civic engagement i believe in
participation in democracy i would never
encourage otherwise
and i recognize if republicans are
telling republicans not to vote
it might lead to republicans losing the
senate and that would be a very good
thing for the country
so i'm not going to get in the way if
you really did believe it was rigged
which it's not
not in favor of democrats in georgia in
georgia you have the opposite you have
republicans who have purged voter rolls
shut down polling places and all of that
stuff but if you really believed it was
rigged and that your vote didn't matter
it follows logically that you might
decide to boycott the election now in
the meantime
let's not be stupid let's phone bank
let's door knock safely
let's register to vote let's request
absentee ballots and let's try to win
these two races on january 5th so we're
going to take a quick break
after the break i will have clips for
you from yesterday's debate
between kelly leffler and rafael warnock
it's wacky
and you can find some of those clips on
our instagram as well
which is davidpakmanshow on instagram
find me on instagram at david.pacman as
well
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you were anything like me you
probably aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video
call with your new doctor you establish
a meaningful relationship with them and
after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
i have some absolutely must-see clips
for you today remember that as we talked
about before the break
some of the 2020 elections aren't over
the presidential election
is over trump lost but the senate is
still to be determined by two runoff
elections both in georgia both on
january 5th the deadline for registering
to vote in georgia
is today online and today by mail must
be postmarked by
today uh december 7th the deadline for
absentee ballot requests
is january 1. early voting starts monday
december 14th a week from today
one of those races is incumbent
republican senator david perdue
against democratic challenger john
ossoff now david perdue will not be
debating john ossoff because john ossoff
completely humiliated david perdue in
the last debate
here is a reminder of that well perhaps
senator perdue would have been able to
respond properly to the kovid 19
pandemic
if you hadn't been fending off multiple
federal investigations for insider
trading
it's not just that you're a crook
senator
it's that you're attacking the health
of the people that you represent that
was absolutely brutal i considered
actually calling and reporting a murder
when i saw that
i've never seen anything like that and
purdue bailed on all future debates
because it was such a disaster but the
other race did have a debate yesterday
unelected incumbent senator kelly lefler
one of the most corrupt senators in the
senate right now
has a challenger in rafael warnock they
debated last night and lefler appeared
to malfunction going into dozens of
repetitions of the same four or five
phrases
it was bizarre she looked like a robot
she didn't move and had this weird
sideways smirk on her face
she mostly refused to even look at her
opponent and
she repeated the same things over and
over and over again
no matter the question no matter the
topic
loffler leffler would just repeat
one of the four or five things that she
said throughout the entire hours debate
which i covered live for you on youtube
twitch and facebook now one of our
viewers
who goes by the name gaslit citizen on
twitter
put this together at my request you're
going to see that no matter the topic
kelly lefler keeps repeating
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal chuck schumer chuck schumer
chuck schumer
the american dream the american dream
the american dream i grew up on a farm i
grew up on a farm
these are all unique instances from the
debate
nothing is repeated here take a look new
deal
i'm fighting for chuck schumer chuck
schumer chuck schumer's chuck schumer
chuck schumer chuck schumer chuck
schumer chuck schumer chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi to live the american
dream the american dream of the american
dream the american dream
the american dream the american dream
the american dream of the american dream
the american dream the american dream
the american dream
the american dream the american dream
the american dream
and the agent of change is my opponent
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock radical liberal
raphael warnock
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal rafael warnock radical liberal
raphael warnock radical liberal rafael
warnock radical liberal rafael warnock
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal rafael warnock radical liberal
rafael warnock radical liberal rafael
warnock is their agent of change
but all those things that you're warning
about would not be happening presumably
with president trump as president so
it almost sounds as though you're
conceding that that part of it has been
settled
and now it's important for the
republicans to to keep the majority in
the senate to
to have a divided government i was born
and raised
on a farm i was born and raised on a
farm i was born and raised on a farm
i grew up working in the fields i grew
up working in the fields i grew up
working in the fields
i waitress my way through school i
waitressed my way through high school
and college and i was the first in my
family to graduate from college
and i was the first in my family to
graduate from college it really is
bizarre
and her use of this phrase radical
liberal raphael warnock
clearly something she thinks will help
her with the georgia electorate and it
may i mean it's possible that she's
doing this because
she can't actually justify staying in
the senate based on anything she's done
so she's just attacking her opponent
here are some instances of that
and check this out wrapping it up in a
bow with socialism at the end
democrats want to fundamentally change
america and the agent of change
is my opponent radical liberal rafael
warnock my opponent
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock has partnered
with
stacy abrams my opponent radical liberal
raphael warnock would be a rubber stamp
and my opponent radical liberal rafael
warnock is his agent of change you've
just heard
radical liberal raphael warnock but my
opponent radical liberal
raphael warnock is a socialist from
radical liberal raphael warnock or we
can take the path of socialism that
radical liberal raphael warnock wants to
bring to our country they want to
radically change our country
and their agent of change is radical
liberal raphael warnock they want to
fundamentally change america and
radical liberal raphael warnock is their
agent of change
look you've just heard radical liberal
rafia warnock
lie about my record i have never seen
anything like this
other than other than it did remind me
of the 2016 republican primary debate
where marco rubio's
software seemed to similarly glitch and
chris christie called him out on it
here's a flashback to 2016 when rubio
seemed unable to repeat anything other
than that same answer
uh about barack obama knows exactly what
he's doing take a look at this
and let's dispel once and for all with
this fiction that barack obama doesn't
know what he's doing he knows exactly
what he's doing but i would add this
let's dispel with this fiction that
barack obama doesn't know what he's
doing
he knows exactly what he's doing in fact
here's the bottom line this notion that
barack obama doesn't know what he's
doing is just not there it is
he knows exactly there it is the
memorized 25 second speech that's the
reason why the campaign is so important
to the gang of eight bill first
well here's the response if i think
anyone who believes that barack obama
isn't doing what he's doing on purpose
doesn't understand what we're dealing
with here
okay this is a president this is a
president who is trying to change this
country
yeah so that uh that was a very strange
event
yesterday's debate was completely
surreal so earlier yesterday you had
john ossoff asking questions of an empty
podium
because his opponent david perdue
refuses to debate him after ossoff
crushed him
and then you have kelly lefler just
stuck on repeat repeating the same
things
they both need to be removed and uh
kelly leffler also continuing to refuse
to accept
that donald trump won the election check
out how she handled
that question and there's a little
glitch in this clip which i apologize
for
yeah my my question is actually pretty
simple
yes or no senator lefler did donald
trump
lose election
you know president trump has every right
to use
every legal recourse available in our
own state we've seen
time and again that we have
investigations that need to be completed
so as you can see we did not get a yes
or no out of her
but she refuses to simply say well yeah
trump did
lose the polling i'm not even going to
show you they're all ties
you have you know i could say oh leffler
is tied in a pole and up one in another
and down one in another
and ossoff is up two but then down these
are all
what i call practically speaking ties
it's going to come down to turn out it's
going to come down to getting the vote
out so you can get involved you can
phone bank you can text bank
you can go and door knock safely if you
are in georgia and of course
you can donate and vote if you live in
georgia as well
so let's just consider these ties and
get to work
donald trump held a huge rally this
weekend
wait what yes he lost the election
yes there's a raging pandemic with
record cases and deaths
and yes trump's rally in georgia had a
huge crowd huge crowd very few masks
and went almost into a third hour of
trump ranting
and trump is still insisting he won the
election the rally hilariously
was ostensibly to support the two
republican senate candidates running in
georgia
trump devoted about 20 minutes of the
nearly three hours to them he's just too
self-centered and narcissistic
to make it about them and you've got to
see this to believe it as i mentioned
this was almost fidel castro like in
nature trump almost went into a third
hour
in valdosta georgia ranting about
whatever crossed his mind
and the upside is this will end soon he
is only president six and a half more
weeks my friend so let's dive directly
into it
because we have a lot to get to trump
kicking off the rally with the lie
that he won the state of georgia
thank you very much and thank you
melania and i want to say
hello georgia we did a great job
you know we won georgia just so you
understand
so trump of course lost georgia joe
biden
won georgia and as scary as it is that a
president still says this a full month
after an election
it's scarier that a crowd of thousands
is cheering it
that's really the scary part hilariously
trump
almost admitted that he lost but then he
backpedaled realizing he was about
to implicitly concede take a look at
this
i think they say that if you win florida
and if you win ohio in history you've
never lost an election this has got to
be our first time
but the truth is they were right we've
never lost an election we're winning
this election
and and of course again
the fact that people cheer for these
lies is horrifying
trump wasn't just declaring non-existent
victories electorally
he also declared victory in the
christmas war the war on christmas a
fake
phony non-existent war proud
hard-working american patriots
let me begin by wishing you all a very
merry christmas remember the word
remember we started five years ago and i
said you're going to be saying christmas
again we say it proudly again
although they'll they'll be trying to
take that word again out of the
vocabulary we're not going to let him do
that
that war doesn't exist neither did the
war on thanksgiving that he talked about
just weeks ago
and then donald trump falsely claimed
that a lot of people are already
vaccinated from covet that was weird
and let me also express our warmest best
wishes and love to all of those people
and families suffering from the
covet pandemic vaccines are on their way
at a level that nobody ever thought
possible it would have taken another
administration five years
it took us seven months and they're
starting next week and we're gonna
start vaccinating and a lot of people
already
are vaccinated it's called you have you
caught it
and you're immune now of course nobody's
been vaccinated other than the people
that were part of the clinical trials
for the vaccines
trump i guess meant people who got the
virus and recovered are immune
just as a reminder we don't know how
long immunity
from recovered patients lasts it's
unclear whether
you are immune longer if you had a more
serious case of the virus versus an
asymptomatic case as an example
very dangerous for trump to be spreading
this type of stuff when we have a raging
pandemic
another incredible moment was trump
telling people
to vote for kelly leffler and david
perdue in the upcoming senate runoffs
while in the same breath saying it's
completely rigged which as we talked
about earlier might actually convince
people not to vote
our estate has had this prominence on
senate races
because they're never together and
this is something that's very important
and you have to get out you have to vote
you have to make sure you have every
vote counted
everybody has to count you got to make
sure they don't throw away any ballots
you got to make sure that when they
collect the ballots and they start
bragging about how many ballots they
already have you got to make sure your
secretary of state knows what the hell
he's doing
and you got to make sure your governor
gets a lot tougher than he's been he's
got to get a lot tougher
you really should vote but it's rigged
trump also attacking the georgia
governor
uh br brian kemp and the georgia
secretary of state brad raffensberger
just
out of this world lunacy at this rally
then trump pulled out the c word
uh no not that one that you might
imagine he would use about kamala harris
this is communism about joe biden and
kamal harris
of course there's not a single
communistic idea in joe biden's platform
not a single socialist idea in the
campaign nor in the incoming
administration so far
these people want to go further than
socialism they want to go into
a communistic form of government and i
have no doubt about it
somehow that doesn't suit georgia too
well that's not
now of course if you go up to anybody at
that rally
and you say yes good evening sir or
ma'am
which biden policies are communistic
ask them what communism even is it will
get very embarrassing very quickly but
they're continuing to harp on this meme
which by the way
the meme might have won george uh
florida for trump
it's conceivable that florida went that
way because the the socialism meme
worked
on cuban americans in florida so i'm not
pretending it doesn't work i'm just
telling you it's bonkers
and then a completely kafka-esque moment
when trump read from printed out sheets
of paper
that have so-called irrefutable facts
about the election take a look at this
or a rigged election there's no way it
could have happened you know it's
uh it's interesting i wrote this out and
i had just a few of the facts which i
think because i want to get onto the
presidentials
i want to i want to stay on presidential
but i got to get to these two because
they're
but listen to this these are the facts
and each fact is like
irrefutable and it means win president
trump received done by
one of the most brilliant political
people president trump received more
votes
than any previous incumbent president in
history
and we lost and we lost
so we received more votes than anybody
in history any incumbent in history
we lost supposedly we didn't lose we're
gonna you're gonna see that
no incumbent who received 75 of the
total primary vote
lost reelection in the history of our
country every single one of these of
course has a but
trump received more votes than any
previous incumbent
but still millions of fewer votes than
joe biden
an incumbent with 75 percent of the
primary vote
has never previously lost but there
really wasn't a republican primary this
year because of the pandemic and the
number is not
causal it's a correlational number in
any case
the entire night was like this again and
again
and just literally hours of it trump
still then
after you know he ranted for two hours
and then still hasn't figured out that
the election is over
listen to this one good and they want to
hurt it very badly and if these two
don't get in
or if i don't get into these dogs we
gotta get
the best would be all three nothing will
happen
[Applause]
[Music]
then there's a hilarious moment where
trump is talking about
who knows what at a rally supposedly
from georgia
uh four georgia senate candidates these
are just non-sequitur rantings i don't
know what he's talking about here
i'd like to say it came from europe no
actually well specifically it came from
italy
italy saying what did we do
they'll wage war on american energy
absolutely decimating george's middle
class they will
your bills will go up not a huge energy
producer but texas remember they said
trump will lose texas by a lot i said
wait a minute i'm in favor of energy i'm
the one that built we have the greatest
energy we've ever had
that is trump rallying in support of
georgia senate candidates
imagine what he would be doing if he was
trying to hurt them rather than help
and then trump claims to have won
wisconsin which he lost
how much and we knew that before but
it's fake news they said wisconsin
a poll came out washington post abc
just before the election i'm going to
lose wisconsin by 17 points i said no
i'm going to win wisconsin
well actually i won wisconsin they're
trying to say he's a little down
but i actually won
and then one more bizarre moment donald
trump talking about the vegetables he
likes
blueberries peppers squash and cucumbers
who
who does cucumbers around here because i
like cucumbers can you i'm the only one
i like uconn absolute
absolute last one trump wrongly telling
people they really need to vote on june
5th
the election is actually on january 5th
but everything that we've achieved
together is on the line on june 5th
so this is funny and you know to see the
the delusional petulant child
who still can't admit he lost but it is
really really dangerous this is
corrosive to democracy
this is a global embarrassment and this
also has the potential to be stochastic
terrorism
trump is railing against poll workers
against the secretary of state against
governors against democrats against
biden saying he stole it they stole it
it's all stolen
this actually can inspire people to
violence and we've already seen
people inspired by these rantings to
start harassing and going after poll
workers in georgia and even other states
so
this has a very real world component
it's not just corrosive to democracy
ideologically
it also actually could inspire real
violence against people
and um again just a few more weeks of
this just a few more weeks of this
let's take a quick break we will be back
with very much
more in just mere moments the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so as we're getting closer and closer to
vaccine approval in the united states
which could come as soon
as thursday or friday of this week
or over the weekend there are more and
more explosive disagreements about
what needs to be done right now in terms
of the virus and there was a
conversation about this that completely
exploded on cnbc a few days ago
now for context if you've been following
the
absolutely horrifying numbers cases in
the united states
have gone off the charts we've had as
many as 200
000 cases per day recently
and it's not just cases that have been
increasing
deaths have also exploded and now
looking like we could have
really a sustained period of 3 000
deaths per day for some time that's
essentially
a 9 11's worth of deaths every single
day now assuming the vaccine is shortly
approved
it's going to be a relatively slow
rollout if you look optimistically
we would have the capacity to vaccinate
maybe six to eight percent of the
population per month
maybe more if we get a second vaccine
maybe even a third vaccine approved and
starting to be supplied
so the point is no matter what the next
three months are going
to be a time where we have to be really
really careful so on cnbc
anchor andrew ross sorkin who has mostly
been in favor of just
following what experts say it's not he's
coming up with this stuff he's mostly
been saying
here's what the medical experts are
saying he was on an interview panel
with correspondent rick santelli and
rick santelli has been wildly out of
control
loudly and defiantly ridiculing and
ignoring
varieties of guidelines and the
situation escalated really quickly let's
take a look
yes no i believe me i believe in careful
and when i point out
governor's cheating it's not for the
hypocrisy which exists
it's the fact that i think many of these
governors are intelligent people
and they love their families which
they've taken out into restaurants
therefore there is actually and should
be an ongoing debate
as to you know why a parking lot for a
big box store
like by my house is jam-packed not one
parking spot open
why are those people any safer than a
restaurant with plexiglass
i i just don't get it and i think
there's a million of these questions
that could be asked
and i think it's really sad that when we
look at the service sector and all the
discussions we've had about job losses
that that particular dynamic isn't
studied more
isn't worked more we don't put more
people in the room and try to figure out
ways
so that these service sector employees
and employers
could all come back in a safer way you
can't tell me that
shutting down which is the easiest
answer is necessarily the
only answer so now here so far
although rick and i could could do would
come to different conclusions
i don't disagree with rick about what
he's saying there are many guidelines
particularly when you look between
states but also within states that
aren't coherent
he says why is it safe to jam-pack a big
box store
but a small restaurant can't be open
that's a great question and in fact
it doesn't appear to be safe to jam pack
the big box store in many states where
people aren't wearing masks especially
big box stores are exactly where a lot
of the contagion is happening
rick is inadvertently getting to an
important point which is
it's not that open all restaurants it's
the big box stores aren't actually safe
back in early november officials in el
paso texas found
a huge number of cases were being
transmitted at
big box stores in el paso including
walmart target home depot and lowe's
so the problem is rick's saying open
everything because the big box stores
are open it seems really what we need is
the big box stores need to dramatically
reduce capacity
so then andrew rossorkin jumps in and
this gets ugly pretty quickly
rick i just i just as a as a as a public
health and public service announcement
uh for the audience the difference
between a big box retailer what is this
hold on the difference between
the tantrums the different the
difference between a big box retailer
hold on the difference between a big box
retailer
and a restaurant or frankly even a a
church are so different it's
unbelievable
going into the big box retail you're
aware i disagree you're welcome you can
have your thoughts and i don't require
you to wear them
it's science i'm sorry it's science if
you're wearing a
500 people at a lowe's aren't any safer
than 150 people in a restaurant that
holds 600
i don't believe it sorry don't believe
me okay
and i live in an area where there's a
lot of restaurants that have fought back
and they don't have any problems
and they're open okay you don't have to
believe it but
let me just say this you're doing a
disservice to the viewer because the
viewers need to understand
the difference you are you are
i i i'm sorry i'm sorry if if i i i
would like to keep our viewers as
healthy as humanly possible
the idea of packing people into
restaurants i think our viewers are
smart enough to make part of those
decisions
so it quickly quickly became no you are
but what am i
um and now rick actually says something
interesting
our viewers are smart enough to decide
on their own
that is just not true i i hate it that
it's not true
check out my video viral video from what
was it a year or so ago
uh we have to accept that a lot of
people are stupid have you seen the
trump rallies where rally-goers are
asked why aren't you wearing a mask and
the answers range from the virus doesn't
exist it's a fake news conspiracy masks
do nothing
i'm protected by jesus because i prayed
the problem
is you need the guidelines to be
stricter than what most people would
need
because there's people that will
disregard them completely
you say outdoor is fine without masks as
was said earlier in the pandemic
then you see hundreds of people packing
narrow hiking trails in california
they found the one way to make outdoor
not safe so now you need to say well you
need masks outdoors as well you got to
close the hiking trails
people aren't smart enough that's an
unfortunate thing let's see the last bit
of this
i don't think that i'm much smarter than
all the viewers like some people do
can i get in here please and get back to
the jobs report how's that working out
for you rick
how's it all working out for you i mean
look at the numbers rick it's working
out fine
i think the numbers rick the lie rick
rick the numbers show that the idea is
so of course the way we've dealt with
this
hasn't been optimal that's absolutely
true
no coordinated federal response going
back 10 months now
um disinformation coming out of the
white house the white house a vector of
disinformation
replacing you know we could pick
anything replacing dr anthony fauci
with a radiologist for months as donald
trump did
um suggesting maybe you inject bleach
and hit the body with the disinfectant
but part of the reason we need to be
fighting uphill
is because of people like uh like rick
santelli so
i i think that um listen i i've said
before
you look at states with high and low
mass usage at least on paper
and sometimes you don't see dramatic
differences in contagion what explains
that well you've got to dig deeper
maybe the state with the high mass usage
on paper people are having more indoor
gatherings because it's a cold state
and so you don't have people abiding by
only hanging out outdoors
i get that there are still many
questions we don't understand
you look at latin american countries on
paper some of the strictest
guidelines and and even actual lockdowns
and they have some incredible rates of
contagion well
when you dig into it you realize on
paper the guidelines are strict nobody's
abiding by them
i get it but we can't pretend
that the problem is merely that all of
the scientists are wrong and have no
idea what's going on it's absolutely
ridiculous and that escalated very very
quickly
a lara trump is it lara or lara
lara trump is donald trump's
daughter-in-law
she's the wife of donald trump's son
eric trump and she's been increasingly
erratic
and cartoonishly histrionic in her
appearances on a bunch of different
right-wing media programs lately
she appeared over the weekend on a few
shows in this first clip i'm going to
play for you she insists
that the election is not over don't you
dare
think joe biden will be sworn in on
january 20th which of course
he will be sworn in on january 20th
because donald trump stops being
president on january 20th at noon but
she says don't you dare think that
we're fighting all the way to the end i
want to make it very clear to the
american people
this is not over so don't for a second
think that joe biden is going to be
sworn in on january 20th
joe biden of course will be sworn in
on january 20th and what she means by
the american people shouldn't think it's
over is
their donors shouldn't think it's over
because they should keep donating money
50 of which trump is using not to file
recounts or
legal challenges but to pay off his own
campaign debt that's what she really
means by that
lara trump also appeared on judge
jeanine pirro's outrageous propaganda
show on fox news
and when lara trump brings up all the
court filings janine
actually seems to be like two percent
connected to reality
and points out that the courts aren't
being moved
by these court filings and of course
they're not because the court filings
are bogus
check out that moment from the interview
state legislatures in so many states
they have held hearings in several
states where we've been able to bring
witnesses forward
to tell their own testimony about what
they saw what happened to them
uh and i mean if you hear some of these
it's not but you know what the
constitution judge jeanine is correct
and of course
with rudy giuliani now positive for
kovid
it's unclear whether he's even going to
be able to continue doing these
court filings which are bogus anyway on
that same episode of judge jeanine
pirro's weekend propaganda hour
lara trump casually says trump won
georgia and also won the election
in a landslide and jeanine pirro is a
statue
she doesn't if you're watching you will
notice janine pirro does not even move
as lara trump says this you know donald
trump won the state of georgia
we know he won this election in a
landslide and we are going to prove that
very very soon
how much of their own base do you think
believes that at this point because
remember that a couple of weeks ago
it's actually crazy it's been almost a
month now it's been more than a month
since the election about a month since
this poll
there was a poll that showed 60 percent
of trump voters believed
that rudy's hearings and lawsuits and
stuff like that
would overturn the election results and
lead to donald trump getting a second
term
starting in just about a month i have to
imagine that that number has declined
since the hearings clearly have gone
nowhere right like it could
i'm guessing maybe 40 percent of trump
voters now believe that this is actually
going to work it must be declining
although
i'd love to see new data on it and then
this next moment
is really sort of a keen insight into
the way that donald trump does business
that this is
it's it's um unintentional genius i
would call it
lara trump sort of says the quiet part
out loud she says listen
trump did a favor to georgia republican
governor brian kemp
trump helped brian kemp become governor
and now brian kemp needs to do donald
trump a favor which is code 4
figure out a way to overturn the results
even though joe biden won
this is how they operate who cares if
it's illegal
kemp owes trump a favor don't you guys
understand
you're right janine governor kemp owes
his uh position as governor
quite frankly to donald trump so you
know it would be nice if he
you know reciprocated in some way not
just to make sure that this goes
the way that we know it went for the
president but for the american people
i mean he owes it to all of us to do the
right thing here
that is really telling that that you're
not really supposed to say that out loud
but that is what it means to have
businessman
trump as president it's all favors even
if they're illegal
and of course politics is favors and
politics is influence peddling in a
sense i'm not naive to that
but it comes down to to what degree and
is it legal
trump lost an election and the favors he
wants include
governors finding illegal ways to
disenfranchise the people
that voted for joe biden and gave joe
biden a victory in those states
so this is all as i've been referring to
it kind of the last
big scam it's the last big con keep
saying they won
keep the base engaged in order to keep
raising money
half of which isn't actually used for
what they claim it's being used for half
is used
to pay donald trump's campaign debt with
rudy
now having covid and the official
electoral vote happening in just a week
what is it that people are even donating
to here i have no idea
but these are really horrible people at
their core and as i've said before they
deserve to never work again
and and the opposite may happen lara
trump reportedly considering running for
senate
in north carolina so the trumps may
never go away but we'll
let's let's table that discussion until
if and until it becomes a reality
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
you know one of the blessings and
simultaneously curses that we've seen
over the last four months
is that the audience has exploded in
size
that's a really great thing from the
standpoint of reaching more people
but it has also brought in all sorts of
new haters
trolls trumpists and tools of the right
wing
movement that are regularly
trolling me and sometimes the critiques
are just really lame
here's a guy who could come up with
nothing more creative to say
than my mouth is physically large he
said my mouth is big
listen to this hello i have a very quick
uh
question for you uh pac-man why is your
mouth so wide
like i'm not here to judge i'm not gonna
say like i'm the perfect looking guy but
you know
it's a very interesting question why why
your mouth is at least you know
200 yards long you can
convert that into metric if you want to
i won't
uh i'd really appreciate if you got my
question as soon as possible and uh
thank you a lot
yeah i mean i think the answer to answer
seriously i think it's just genetics
right i mean i
i i assume i am the genetics of uh
of my parents but this is the type of
stuff that is
i mean it's daily stuff like this uh
there's another guy obsessed with the
fact that
i use my hands when i talk that's the
big critique of the show
it doesn't matter what i say it doesn't
matter what what anybody
i'm using my hands when i talk so i'm
hoping that a lot of these folks as they
i think they may be on a come down in a
sense
as they realize that joe biden's going
to be president and so they still want
to keep calling in and
attacking and engaging but there's no
factual basis on which to engage with me
because biden won and they're furious
and
and all of that so instead they're
focusing on stuff like this
it's sad to see but unfortunately it's
very
very common and uh we to some degree i
believe we'll have to continue dealing
with it we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today
in california there is growing anger
about stay-at-home orders and we are
starting to hear from
sheriffs who say they will not be
enforcing the stay-at-home orders and
i have a lot to talk about regarding
this uh we also now are seeing
lab-grown meat go on sale for the first
time we've been covering lab-grown meat
for a decade
from when it was 300 000 for an ounce
and we said the price will come down
this will be a thing in our lifetimes
no kill lab-grown meat is now going on
sale for the first time we will talk
about it
and also very interesting revelations
about my accent i have friends from the
south
who say i have a new york accent
obviously i don't they just i think a
lot of us northerners sound
the same to them um i have people who
write and say oh david you're based in
boston i can hear your boston accent
i've never believed i had a boston
accent i didn't grow up in boston
and we finally have taken a dialect test
and
the revelations are explosive i hope
that they don't end the show because
they are controversial but we will
discuss all of that and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
slash david pakman steady md lets you
maintain a meaningful long lasting
relationship with a primary care
physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or co-pays
visit
steadymd.com pacman to get started